welcome to this video a new video on one
of my over theboard games yeah very
recent game as you see um at the date
that is um attached here near the game
information on the right hand side of
the board yeah this was played in the
the Belgium league and um in terms of um
circumstances of the game one needs to
know that um in the Belgium League um
they have um yeah you can uh beforehand
you can guess what opponent you might
play but it's not um so easy to to guess
exactly because um most teams have um
long list of possible players that can
play and it's sometimes like okay it's
one of those five guys and uh you're not
going to start to prepare for five
people so in reality um I didn't know um
who I was playing and probably the same
thing also applied for my opponent so he
couldn't expect to play me the same as I
couldn't expect to play him um I
actually didn't know that he was even in
the opposing team on the list so let's
see what happens my opponent is
um David David mear from the
Netherlands he is an international
Master with the rating of 23 39 71 he's
u in his mid 20s so still a bit bit
younger yeah let's see what happened um
I played Knight F3 as I usually do when
I don't really know what to expect yeah
when when I have some certain idea what
the opponent is playing I sometimes will
go C4 or D4 according to um the
opponent's repertoire if I don't know
what they do I normally play Knight F3
it's simply the safest Choice avoiding
all kinds of of sharp lines like bonis
and and bco gambits and whatnot not that
I believe that these openings are so
super great but I rather have some um
yeah idea beforehand that they come up
on the board so I can prepare something
or at least refresh my theoretical
knowledge yeah we got to a Queen's
Gambit wire
transposition and here he played the
move C5 this is is the improved tush or
improved is probably weird considering
that the main thing here compared to the
tarush is the normal tarush is that
after C takes black wants to avoid the
isolated Pawn with Knight takes D5 also
sometimes called the semi tarash yeah
this is in fact a line that nowadays is
getting kind of popular due to the
efforts of crnic amongst others one
reason is that for years it was believed
that this
line this line
exactly um is better for white um at
least to some extent better for white um
but um yeah it seems to be very solid
for black very often they get the queen
here Rook to d8 and B6 it's fairly it's
a fairly solid and simple to play
position um I expected that to happen
when my opponent played C5 however after
this capture he took with the E Pawn and
this was um a big surprise because it is
actually rather well known that this is
not a very precise move order he takes
D5 in this precise position is a mistake
and um this is due to the move Bishop G5
it's really a mistake it's not like yeah
okay you can do it it doesn't matter
very much it is a mistake due to Bishop
G5 the reason is that now there is
intermediate pressure along this
diagonal and um the problem is that
black has some problems now that are
really really concrete I'm threatening
now to take F6 to damage his Pawn
structure so he cannot play yeah stuff
like that let's say after Queen takes
I'll just win the pawn which is the
threat anyway and G takes I mean is is
just a terrible structure this kind of
thing he has to do something about this
diagonal and the pawn on D5 basically
two moves Bishop E7 or Bishop E6 um
Bishop
E6 is um the main alternative here I
knew that white gets a good game now by
means of playing E4 or by taking on F6
and then E4 it's it can lead to the same
thing um to show you the general IDE
this kind of thing yeah the point is
that there's an immediate immediate
attack on D5 and if black takes on e4
white can also insert this intermediate
check yeah something like this yeah this
in fact has been played in um in a um
simultaneous game simultaneous display
in uh 1924 by Alexander aline the um
later World champion and this is in fact
um a game that I knew because I only
recently had used it in a in a training
session with a student of mine so this
memory that this line was bad was pretty
fresh in my mind um yeah he went Bishop
E7 and he took took some moments maybe
he remembered that uh this in fact uh
wasn't that great and um he was um yeah
trying to to find um at least some sort
of good practical defense m
I I after the game I had a look at his
opening repertoire actually and found
out that only recently he had added the
tarash queen gam Tash defense to his
repertoire but it seems that um he yeah
he didn't uh know or forgot about this
this move order issue um to just put
this into perspective the normal move
order in the Tash would be
this C5 five to get to this
line and here black has this this Choice
Knight C6 or Knight F6 and Knight F6
here is the imprecise move you have to
play this to avoid the pin if White NOW
wants to get the same thing with Bishop
G5 you'd of course don't play Knight F6
with a self pin but you can play Bishop
E7 or you can play F6 both moves are are
totally okay to um to address this issue
of the bishop
yeah and in the game he was in this pin
and in trouble exactly here yeah he
played Bishop E7 and now we see an
additional problem white can just take
yeah and now I always have this idea to
capture here and capture on D5 there is
in immediate immediate pressure on the
pawn yeah he went with developing Knight
C6 and I went E3 it's important not to
take now because something like
this here isn't that clear yeah here
black will get probably the pawn back
and then yeah you have given up the
bishop pair and yeah it's nothing
nothing great white um must uh make sure
not to to clarify things prematurely
also of course this
is really bad due to this blundering the
queen so I just want to develop not this
but develop E3 is just is
better yeah now the whole thing gets uh
gets more interesting with the capture
on F6 and on D5 so he went Bishop E6 to
cover the pawn um if he instead
castles um and instead of Bishop E6 if
he castles um I can play Bishop B5 like
in the game or also Bishop B2 or queen
B3 come into consideration ation it it's
pretty similar actually yeah well Bishop
E6 was played and here yeah white has a
choice where to develop um the bishop
again it's not advisable to do anything
concrete yeah or or or yeah hurry with
some things um I could have taken for
example like this which um tries to keep
this Pawn but black will always have
chances to get it back with Queen A5 or
even the bishop back so I think I think
this is um somewhat somewhat early this
capture um possible but still I didn't
like it so much I went um with a
different a different a different move
here I just played the developing move
Bishop B5 I think this is also a good
choice the idea is to at some point to
threaten to take here and go B4 to keep
the pawn so if he castles now for
example I can consider to grab this
pawn it seems that in fact this isn't
that great yeah I in the game I thought
that this would be excellent but black
actually gets some uh decent play here
with this pin and um I don't get to D4
which is a huge problem if I would um be
able to play Knight D4 this would be
great because I attack this uh this Pawn
all the time but due to the pin I don't
manage and and here this isn't so clear
I mean I'm a pawn up but it's not um
it's not totally convincing however I
have an alternative if you would have
castled um I mean I'm not sure if I
would have played that but the the
simple move castles is actually strong
just um going on with my development the
point is that um in a way I'm I'm asking
me okay what what's your next move and
this idea is still in the position if he
tries to get
the get the pawn back now here I have
this this continuation fairly typical
winning the pawn and one problem is if
he takes now I just recapture and with
this Tempo on the bishop I will keep my
extra Pawn in this case here I even will
manage to take off the Knight with
further damage to his Pawn structure so
there is Queen takes B2 that needs to be
played and then white has the strong
move move Knight C7 which is um very
important attacking the rook and
threatening to take the E6 Bishop with a
damage to his Pawn structure it also
keeps the bishop covered it's quite um
quite funny if black now plays a move
like Rook to d8 with a Tempo I have the
important resource Queen C1 with an
attack on the bishop so the what will um
happen here it will happen um that um he
will have a damag pawn structure it's
very hard for him to avoid that yeah
with Knight E6 and Bishop C6 it's a very
good position for white and um something
that actually could have happened in the
game um in in a in a comparable
situation or even with a trans position
okay let's go back to the actual
game instead of castles here he took
immediately yeah um I wasn't totally
sure about the precise or what the most
precise move order is at the end I
decided to Castle and I mean at the end
sounds like I took a long time I didn't
played this relatively quickly because I
wanted to um yeah to have the king out
of the way it is simply I always want to
have this kind of idea but Queen takes
B2 is such an annoyance or in this case
we even have this and my king is is
forced to move so I I thought that okay
I cannot really go without castling here
so I went uh I went with this move um
rather rather
quickly castles yeah and now what what
should black do I still have this idea
with the the
capture it's um it's not not easy at
all he went Bishop E7 um if he castles
here
we get the same thing that I had shown
before this
um this business is the same
position note that in this position
Bishop takes C6 which even looks a bit
stronger yeah because this this looks
very nice
actually yeah when when when white will
be able to take here and settle him with
yet another Pawn weakness but on Bishop
takes C6 he has the funny reply Rook a
to d8 intermediate move of course I
didn't see that and after that white
still keeps an edge but it's not very
much it's really funny yeah the queen is
protecting B7 so Bishop B7 is useless
and um yeah this way he just avoids this
Knight C7 for quite funny um and a move
that probably a human wouldn't wouldn't
spot maybe when you at the
in this precise position maybe but to
anticipate it is very difficult yeah
this was the game position and he went
Bishop to E7 making sure that he can
recapture on F6 with the bishop yeah and
here I really I wasn't really sure I was
thinking that probably both Queen A4 and
Knight D4 both leads to an
advantage and uh I couldn't really tell
what's better so after relatively quick
thought I went with Queen A4
and um in tournament chess I'm really a
relatively quick player I'm not um much
for considering super long what the most
precise move is if I see two or three
good ones I tend to play one of those
quicker quicker than it it it might have
the impression from from my Blitz games
where I tend to uh spend long time but
lots of this time um is spent on
explaining the thought process which I
think adds to the videos but makes me
use more time in over the board chess
I'm I'm playing relatively quickly yeah
here he has a problem yeah I'm just
threatening to grab the pawn on C6 and
on Rook C8 I just take A7 hm and this is
just a pawn for
nothing this is why he went Queen
B6 and here again here here was a
position where I thought it for a bit
but I really couldn't decide what I like
most because well there are three moves
this
one this one both more Rooks to the
defile very logical putting pressure on
D5 there's Knight D4 which looks
attractive yeah those three moves um and
to be honest I'm not totally sure what's
best maybe Rook 81 is best but this is
due to an idea that is very computer is
that I simply couldn't see I mean the
computer wants to play Rook 81 with a a
very nice line actually after Rook 81
what should black do probably castles
yeah it is
um necessary at one point and now the
computer wants to take take
here and in this position which is very
comparable to the game in the game I
used the other Rook so The Rook is here
on A1 in my position in the
game here I was thinking in the game
that I want to play Rook to B1 this this
Rook is attacked here The Rook is not
attacked as it is on F1 and here the
computer gives a very strong move that I
couldn't really see Knight
G5 it's a move that is in a way somewhat
computer is because while it puts yet
another piece on the fifth rank in a
sort of weird configuration but it is it
is very strong the reason why it is
strong is there are concrete ideas the
most concrete one is this threatening
Checkmate and threatening the bishop so
even after
H6 I have this move which is very strong
takes takes and then A6 looks good
because of the pin but this is answered
by again the very computerist line like
that winning the
queen yeah this is the kind of stuff
that is very difficult to see in in a in
a real game at least
for for yeah let's say uh non- geniuses
I don't know it's it seems difficult I
couldn't really decide uh what line I
like most there's also after Queen B6
this Knight D4 move this I actually
considered and thought that it is good
for white but at the end I decided on
Rook fd1 but okay Rook C8 and here I
thought that maybe E4 is um is an idea
and the computer actually agrees that
this uh kind of complications um are
interesting the idea is that after a
capture
white is having this move to set up the
capture so there might be something like
this
happening which is obviously quite nice
yeah those three Pawn weaknesses are are
something for white yeah I mean this
also was a nice line but I couldn't
really evaluate it uh properly I went
with um rook fd1 and I still like the
choice I mean it it keeps an advantage
without any any doubt and this is the
most important thing he he
castled and now I can take on F6 and uh
go from
there this of course now is pretty much
forced grabbing this and when we got to
this position here he surprised me I
think in in fact the
game um really only has two um two
Mistakes by black to to be honest the
the opening with e takes D5 leads to
problems and here exactly here I believe
he's um committing a mistake um from
which he will not recover I think um
here he played Knight to
E7 yeah attacking my Rook at the same
time um it allows to play Rook D2 to
keep the B2 Pawn I think he here he must
capture B2 simply to restore M
materially quality
um and um yeah I'm I guess he was seeing
some some ghosts after this um it is
clear um of course that white will keep
an edge but it's not um that clearcut to
be honest I will thinking and this is in
fact this is right yeah Rook B1 is right
getting this Tempo he has to retreat and
my idea in the calculation when I went
with my Rook F2 D1 was Bishop D3 with a
tempo Queen to C7 yeah he must protect
B7 and then I I was anticipating this
position and here I thought that okay
well all my pieces are active yeah Rook
here Rook here Queen Bishop is
active and sometimes it can um be that I
can even develop a kingside attack
somewhat uh typical or comparable to
some of those old um games by alak kind
where he was a attacking on the queen
side and all of a sudden via the fourth
and fifth rank he was switching forces
to the king side I was thinking that
this kind of thing could easily happen
just imagine in this position I could
somehow jump the queen over to F5 yeah
yeah then M on H7 is threatened and he
has no defense as G6 loses the bishop
these kind of things can easily happen
um for example a move like Queen G4 here
looks dangerous because it threatens
exactly this and Rook D7 however Rook d8
is defending for black um it turns out
that um when you inspect this position a
bit closer that maybe moves like Rook D2
B5 or Bishop E4 as are strong I didn't
actually see that far that exactly
Bishop E4 seems to be strong what the
engine is giving but um I was simply
relying on the on the on my uh intuition
that there should be something in this
position and Bishop E4 is strong the
idea is to intensify this pressure on
the queen side is very difficult to
defend for black one possible defense is
something like this Rook d8 Rook B5 and
here we come to the point that there
will be there will be some material loss
yeah on A7 on C6 on B7 it's very hard to
prevent Rook B8 and now very strong
white here can try to win a pawn or
wants to win a Pawn on the queen side
but black has uh really no big
opportunity to avoid it so what white
should do is to play some improving
moves like
this and ultimately there will be one
Pawn lost it's very likely that
something like that will happen this
kind of end
game this end game and um this is in
fact um interesting um interesting to to
look at from a from a technical point of
view I think um this should ultimately
win for white have a very compact Pawn
structure with stuff on one side of the
board the Knight is actually favored
over the bishop as it can attack all
Targets while the Bishop is sometimes
pointing Into Thin Air um and I'm on the
seventh rank I think white should win
this ultimately but it's um um still a
difficult thing ahead um what we need to
do is I mean this is not a very nice
Prospect but in the game when he went
with Knight E7 here yeah this this move
Knight D7 after Rook D2 we can have a
look what what happens in the game and
see how yeah I mean how how bad this is
he went with Rook to d8 can also take
the other Rook it's not not a huge
difference actually um it's a bit better
but not a huge difference if we consider
stuff like that for
example um the The Rook here has one
advantage compared to taking the other
Rook it it covers F7 but still there are
always problems for black for example if
he tries to get this back there is
things things like that are happening on
F7 on H7 and there are tactical ideas as
well yeah with Bishop F7 and queen8
those kind of things um this is in fact
lost for black it is uh super difficult
to defend it's not just the pawn the
pawn is one one problem but the main
thing is that with the bishop coming on
C4 he will also be attacked I'm on the D
defa there is a weak back rank yeah if
we consider let's say he would play
something like that this actually could
have happened in the game then I have
things um to play um yeah I can play
against his back rank with tactical
moves like that or queen B3 it's maybe
stronger even attacking the queen and he
cannot capture because of checkm yeah so
black has a ton of problems and it's not
mattering that much he went Rook fd8
Rook d one takes takes A6 Bishop C4 yeah
and this is uh the point yeah I'm having
this pressure here and always something
coming to D7 a rook or a queen it's uh
it's really um yeah it's really it's
lost this is a loss position it requires
some precise play but it's not said not
that difficult he went Rook C8 I'm sorry
this was the wrong button here he went
Rook C8 if he takes now on B2 again
there is this Knight G5 business this is
even worse of course because now F7 is
is it's like totally hanging yeah um
it's not the only thing actually in the
game I was also thinking that even a
move like
that is um is very strong um he is
forced to
trade and now Rook D7 this is not as as
good and forceful as Knight G5 I just
want to show the general idea look at
this position this is a super strong
piece black has a hard time to move any
of his pieces his Bishop is uh is tied
to the defense here he cannot move
anywhere there is the threat of E5
winning the piece and if he moves the
Knight F7 is lost so the combined
pressure on the seventh Rank and the
bishop is just very very problematic
even this is strong but Knight G5 um as
shown here Knight G5 is even better yeah
so he couldn't take on B2 and he went
with this Rook C8 move yeah here here
there's I think the only spot where um
yeah I actually think I I made a really
good move the other things were pretty
uh pretty clear and obvious um here
white can play something something lame
yeah and probably win not doing normal
move let's say but I was thinking that
the strongest move and this is actually
supported by the computer at the end is
the move G4 and uh this I'm very
satisfied with that I played it because
in former times I often had problems
with moving Pawns in front of my king
that weakened the king side or the king
position in this case G4 is just strong
it is the most forceful continuation
threatening G5 winning the piece
basically it's Bishop is strapped and
this in fact um intensifies the pressure
to the utmost he now has absolutely no
defense and my king
is not um under under attack or
something it also gives me the
desired um space so that the back rank
is not that weak yeah he does not have
after a move like that he does not have
this with a Mia on the back rank he went
H6 and I played Bishop B3 here here the
computer gives Rook D7 as even stronger
but this is totally sufficient yeah it
gets the bishop out of this attack it
allows the queen to swing over to the
most attractive Square on e4 and it sort
of covers B2 from from the queen so
Bishop B3 is is a good and strong move I
think Rook D7 was technically stronger
but it is totally sufficient rook
d8 and queen C4 this was another point
of course of Bishop B3 attacking F7 now
he has to play Rook f8 yeah Rook d8 does
not look great if you now have to go
back but there is really no move anymore
if he goes with this for example I'm
pushing H4
really and and G5 it's just it's just
gone there is no defense to this attack
note that if he moves the Knight for
example the whole thing I mean let's
let's just do
this and and and resigns yeah the G Pawn
push is just
decisive so he he played this this this
move Rook d8 which okay looks a bit
unlucky but because you have to move it
again but there really wasn't anything
to be done about it rook f8 and H4 yeah
threatening
G5 Knight went here and Rook D7 here we
are in the territory where many moves
win but Rook D7 is uh attacking F7 again
and well yeah he has to do it he played
Knight h8 I must admit that I rather
would have resigned here than putting
the knight in the corner but yeah it's
there's nothing nothing to be done um
Queen D5 simple and strong here it
attacks B7 he went R Queen to B4 with a
counter attack here and just E4 yeah
keeping the pawn on G4 and now again
renewing the idea is G5 Rook takes B7 he
protected his Pawn by advance
and now um I have a simple continuation
A3 the queen only has one move to A5 and
now E5 is playable as there is no attack
anymore on G4
E5 Bishop to d8 so he had to retreat
this to the back rank as well and now E6
yet after this move he he had enough and
and resigned yeah there is there is
nothing that that black can do anymore
something like this is
leading to a very quick mate due to the
various pins here um yeah he actually he
just made two mistakes I believe in the
game the the opening and this Knight E7
move after um the capture on B2 if we go
back to this um critical situation once
more this was here here I think he
really should take B2 and uh try to to
suffer in this position here at least
he's not Material down immediately I
understand that this is not a very
attractive Prospect but um yeah he
already was in in deep trouble um and it
shows that um imprecise move orders um
Can can cost you a whole game sometimes
I mean at least um he was in a position
of suffering after move six so uh or
move five however you want to put it
yeah and it's that's a very useful thing
to remember actually for D4 player that
in this position you shouldn't play the
routine move G3 like you normally do in
the
tarash but Bishop G5 which really puts
pressure on the opponent immediately
white has a huge score here like close
to 70% yeah I hope you enjoyed the
coverage of this game there will be more
over theboard games covered in about
let's say two two and a half weeks when
I have U when I have played the
tournament in Bat vce the open Bavarian
championships will be many more games to
discuss um yeah I hope you enjoyed it
and um yeah I'll be back with more of
those as mentioned
bye